[Musique]
ici les communes des outrmers c'est
quelque chose d'important c'est pas 212
parmi 35000 c'est quelque part le modèle
communal qui peut être un modèle de
vivre ensemble de proximité de relation
avec les citoyens et c'est me
semble-t-il ce dont nous avons le plus
besoin dans notre pays dans sa diversité
aujourd'hui il faut absolument qu'on
retrouve ce lien fort qu'on puisse
exercer nos fonctions en toute sérénité
la volonté aujourd'hui qui est de dire
qu'il faut qu'on travaille sur les
conditions d'exercice du mandat est
essentielle si on veut recréer du
dynamisme retrouver de l'engagement
notamment sur chez celles et ceux qui ne
sont pas encore
élus aujourd'hui nous rattrapons un
retard par rapport à à l'Hexagone sur
les réseaux que ce soit de l'eau potable
ou même de l'assainissement un travail
est fait ça il faut le reconnaître mais
pas assez pour pour les usagers ça se
répercute sur la population parce
qu'aujourd'hui B elle n'a pas
d'eau un état profondément déconcentré
doté d'une agilité normative outre mer
est de plus en plus impératif pour
répondre à l'aspiration unanimement
partagée d'une coconstruction des
politiques publiques sur nos
territoires nous avons à cœur ici au
Sénat euh de leur dire et leur redire
combien nous sommes attachés finalement
à la commune dans son ensemble que ce
soit ici sur le territoire métropolitain
ou en outrem et combien nous avons à
cœur d'apporter des réponses à leurs
problèmes du
[Musique]
quotidien